hi there welcome to this course on
getting started with the java platform
my name is matt speak i'm your
instructor for the course and
in this course we're going to go through
all of the um kind of introductory
things that you need to know
about the java platform to be able to
get started in other words to start your
um kind of like developer career if you
like with java platform
so a few things to say about this course
um first off this is a course for
complete and absolute
total beginners so it doesn't matter if
you've maybe had a little look at java
before
or if you know nothing about java
whatsoever don't worry about that i take
things completely from first principles
so you're not going to get stuck you're
not going to get into any kind of like
um issues where you're not sure how
things work just of course it's going
too quickly
everything in this course is designed to
be completely and totally
absolute beginners i promise you it's
absolute beginners so you should be fine
for this
so that's all well and good but what's
actually included in the course what are
you actually going to learn
so in general you're going to learn
three things three things you're going
to get out of this course
and that's basically that we're going to
get you set up with the tools that you
need to be able to
program in java so there's a certain set
of tools that we need to get installed
onto your system so we're going to get
you up and running with that so you'll
be able to
get started and take it further you'll
have all the tools installed in your
system by the end of the course
the second thing is that we're going to
look into core concepts of java
obviously core concepts we mean
basically
the the absolute fundamentals that you
need to know to be able to get started
with the platform
so if you've heard terms like for
example jvm jdk
jre ig things like that class files buy
code
don't worry about all of that now we're
going to explain it all over the next
few lessons so you're familiar with
those core concepts
and finally the other thing the third
thing you're going to get out of this
course is you're really going to get a
feel for java
so by the end of the course you're going
to know whether you want to take it
further you know how it kind of feels to
you it's a programming language
as a development environment um i think
you'll take it further because it's a
really
fun um and exciting programming
environment to to program in
um but at the end of the course you'll
know yourself and you'll be able to make
your own decision
so those are the three things you're
going to get out of this course okay you
set up with the tools
here you set up with the core concepts
and you'll have a feel to know whether
you want to take it further
okay so if all that sounds good to you
let's get started
we're going to have a look at the java
platform as a whole and
we're going to basically see the core
features of java
and we're going to see why and java's
become so popular in the marketplace
have a look at who uses it and what kind
of features and benefits it gives us
and really yeah you're going to get kind
of like a flavor of
of the bigger picture if you like so
actually what java is so let's jump in
so the first thing to know about java is
that java is the world's
number one programming platform right
now today in 2021
and this is really quite exciting
because it actually means that you're on
the cusp of learning something
extremely valuable obviously with that
marketable as well but
all of that as a package together and i
want you to realize this takes you to
the place right now
where you're on the cusp of learning
something really exciting and even
potentially life-changing for you as
well
now i don't see this lightly but to be
honest if you want to have
a career as a developer as a software
engineer then pretty much
java is the best option for you at this
particular time because it's been
popular now for well over a decade um
it doesn't look like it's going to
change anytime soon with all of the
um different features that have been
evolved the
marketplace share that it has the kind
of foothold that it has
in the market in other words like all
the different companies that are using
it
and that kind of thing so this genuinely
is a really really really exciting
opportunity for you
if you feel like you'd maybe want to go
down that route of being becoming a
professional
software engineer now don't just take my
word for it we can look at a website
there's
a website called i'm not sure i
pronounce it's tayobi.com
or tirbe.com it stands for the
importance of being earnest
and what it does is it tracks the
popularity of programming languages
by looking at the amount of web searches
that people have done for that
particular programming language
i'm kind of plotting them in a graph as
we'll see so if we just jump in now i've
got chrome up here
uh popular web browser if i just jump
into tayabi.com
here we can see we've got the website
for it and right over here on the right
hand side you'll see this tayub
index so if we click that and we just
scroll down
you'll see that there's a graph at the
bottom of the page so here we are
so this graph is basically charting the
popularity of
the most popular programming languages
that there are today um and you can see
it's here it's giving you've got a c
java python c plus plus c sharp these
are different programming languages that
you can choose to
go up software in the main thing that i
want to point out here is if we click on
one of these
specifically click on the java one then
from this you can clearly see
by looking at the line graph that's
highlighted which is the one in black
just the one for java
you can clearly see that java pretty
much in general is ranked over and above
any of the other languages
so while there might be some contenders
for that kind of number one spot
namely with javascript and python which
you may have heard about in spite of
this
java is still pretty much number one and
it looks like it's going to continue
that way for quite some time
so just know that what you're actually
learning in this course when you're
establishing the beginning of that
journey as a job a software engineer
you're learning something
that is very marketable and ultimately
going to be very profitable for you as
well for the foreseeable future so i
just wanted to point that out first of
all
so we've seen that java is the number
one programming language today
the next question you probably have is
well okay who's using it then well
pretty much all of the big players today
use java as a development platform and
so if we go through some of these now
google use it so you're obviously
familiar with google the popular search
engine the most popular search engine in
the world
that uses java on the back end to power
its products amazon
huge e-commerce store the biggest
e-commerce store in the world they use
java 2.
and why would companies like google and
amazon choose to use java
the reason for that is because of java's
so-called scalability what that means i
won't go into too much but what it means
basically is if you think about it
with amazon or with google you have
pretty much
millions of people at any one time who
are making requests on the website
so for example in amazon they're looking
up orders
looking things up in the product catalog
making orders changing things getting
recommendations all that kind of stuff
millions of people at the same time are
using that website
and this is possible because of the
power of java because of its scalability
for java you can pretty much and kind of
like chain different java processes
together
kind of like grouping a whole load of
computers together if you like
so that the total combined power of all
of those computers together
can be used at the same time to be able
to deal with all those millions of
requests
so that's pretty much the power of java
so it's an incredibly powerful language
and it's something in fact the main
thing that's the reason for its
popularity places like google and amazon
but it's not just search engines and
e-commerce sites we also have streaming
services as well
so for example spotify the popular music
streaming service that uses java
in addition netflix they also use java
as well the reason they use it
is because again it's about java
scalability this aspect that it can be
very powerful
i can service multiple clients that
means multiple people
on their different devices millions of
those people at the same time
but it's not just limited to those
companies either if you look at social
media for example
we'll see that facebook use it twitter
uses it
linkedin uses it pinterest and instagram
use it as well
so by now you should be getting a real
picture of the scope of java
you know google amazon spotify netflix
all the social media companies facebook
twitter linkedin
pinterest instagram i mean this is huge
it really is huge if you ever want to
get into something
or rather some form of technology that
has a future java is the thing to be
getting into so it's good that you're on
this course to be uh to make those first
steps into that java development career
so all these big companies use it where
is it use them well various different
places it's used in
mobile phones and tablets the android
platform for example
is based entirely in java and so
therefore java is the backbone all
android devices
but not just handheld devices either we
also see java in huge cloud-based
applications powered by hundreds of
different servers at the same time
surf is just a fancy name for a computer
that allows a website to run by the way
we see java used there as well and
that's because of its power that we've
just seen
in fact java powers three billion
devices
all around the world which is pretty
phenomenal if you think about it three
billion that's a massive number so on
three billion different devices
all around the world java's running
providing this powerful backbone
for all these devices across the world
globally pretty exciting stuff i think
you'll agree
so if everybody's using it and java's so
popular why is it so popular
well there are a few reasons for java's
popularity and let's just dip into a few
of them now
if you understand all of these don't
worry i don't expect you to understand
them but we'll just give a few bullet
points what makes java just so popular
so first up is platform independence and
what this means is that java has this
idea called write ones run anywhere
which we'll see shortly
and that means that you can write a
program once or one machine for example
on windows
and then you can run it on all of the
different machines so you can run it on
a linux machine or a mac
or a unix server or wherever else and so
we have this notion of platform
independence
which is a hugely powerful concept it
means that effectively you don't have to
rewrite the same software in other words
reprogram it reprogram your application
that is you don't have to redo that
for each different machine type so for
example supposing i'll write an
application on windows
and then i want to release it i have the
ability then to release it on mac
and on linux without having to reprogram
the whole application
in mac or reprogram the whole
application in linux so that's the first
thing platform independence
now the second thing pretty much is the
thousands of libraries that we have
so in java there's this whole kind of
software movement called open source
and in a nutshell what that means is
that people have already written
components
those are kind of like mini applications
if you like which you can assemble
together to make your own application
people have already created all of these
libraries all these different components
there are literally thousands of them
and they're available completely for
free now what this means to you
is that you don't have to write that
code it's code that you get for free you
can just incorporate that code into your
applications
and use the features which that
component gives you so
very powerful very beneficial having
this idea of so-called reusable
components
that's another key benefit of java as
well additionally as we've seen we've
got the versatility of the platform the
fact that you can write applications
which run on a mobile device
small scale so just for an individual
user or you can write applications which
are designed to be used for
millions of users using java in the
cloud the cloud by the way is just
a fancy term pretty much of um saying
that you have hundreds or thousands of
computers all working together to do
one particular thing or execute one
particular program which in the case of
amazon for example will be its website
don't get hung up on the idea of a cloud
but that's just basically what the cloud
means here java has this versatility to
be able to run on one device or on
hundreds or thousands of devices at the
same
time very powerful very beneficial for
companies as well since they can build
huge ecommerce stores like amazon we've
seen
another aspect to java's popularity is
the market share that it has kind of
like the foothold in the marketplace
so because so many different people use
java so many different companies rather
use
java plus as well because it's been
going for 25 years now i think it's
about 25 years i think it was 1996 when
it came out
and because of that it means that there
are a lot of skills on the marketplace
people who know java it also means
because we have so many different
companies using it and different
developers using it
there's a very lively kind of community
and a huge source of documentation java
technology itself which is also
really really useful which also brings
us to this idea of the developer
ecosystem
that's basically all of the tools and
technologies that surround java itself
that have been developed to make your
life as a java developer
much easier so all of this together as a
package for you personally
means that java's got a bright future
it's got tremendous job opportunities a
market opportunity for you personally
it's pretty easy to use and versatile to
get pretty complex stuff programmed
quickly and easily because of all of the
different libraries that you have as
well
and there's a ton of documentation out
there and useful tools which can help
you get started
so that's an overview of the java
platform itself now let's have a look at
the java language which has also been
central to java's success
so the reason the java language is so
popular which is pretty much the heart
of the platform itself
comes down to a few key reasons as well
so first up we have the fact that it's
pretty simple to use
it's simple to use it's easy to
understand it's got less of a path
or rather less of a learning curve for
you when you get started
so it's a pretty accessible language to
be able to just pick up and start to get
started with
so that's one of the key benefits also
related to that notion of versatility
that we've seen earlier is the idea that
it's object oriented so
object oriented is a kind of a style of
programming
you have different styles there's
functional programming procedural
programming
object-oriented programming we don't
have to go into detail about those right
now
but in object-oriented programming you
basically program objects
and these different objects interact
with each other and it's basically a
very powerful way of being able to
quickly write systems which are easy to
understand easy to develop
and easy to maintain and extend okay so
moving on another aspect of java is the
fact that it's fully rounded and what i
mean by that is that it gives you access
to
be able to do everything you'd want to
do pretty much with a computer
so that means for example being able to
test a computer network access disks
files folders that kind of thing as well
as interact with
desktop so that means for example
drawing windows and buttons and having
drop down menus all that kind of stuff
java's pretty much got apis for all of
that stuff completely out of the box
which means that you don't have to write
that kind of stuff you can just reuse
the existing code that the java platform
already gives you you'll be able to
access networks
read files writer files construct
windows with xboxes and buttons on all
that kind of stuff
so that's been a good high level
overview of the java platform as you can
see it's really exciting platform to
program in and you're probably really
excited to get started now
which we'll do in the next videos
we're going to look at the java platform
itself specifically we're going to look
at the key components of the java
platform
and see how they all slot together let's
dive in now before we start
i just have to give you a quick word of
warning about java in java just like any
form of technology or any form of
programming it's not specific to java
this is any form of programming or
anything to do with it
there are always going to be lots of
acronyms but those are abbreviations for
things
you're going to hear things like jdk jvm
jre things like that don't worry about
that we're going to define those
shortly it's just a word of warning
about that and also not only acronyms
we're going to have a lot of terminology
as well
so we're going to hear terms like byte
code source code class file compilation
those kinds of things
again when you first hear a word that
sounds technical or you come across
these abbreviations
it can seem kind of daunting because
because you don't know what the acronyms
and terminology means
but don't worry about that don't be
dissuaded don't be put off we'll explain
all of these
in this course which means give you that
quick word of warning so yeah above all
don't panic that's the key thing do not
panic all will be explained
now let's start off with the key point
about java
which is this notion of platform
independence java has this idea of
something called wara w-o-r-a
which stands for write once run anywhere
and this means that you can take
a java program and you can run it on
multiple machines
let's have a dive in now and see exactly
what this means together so let's start
with my mac
so i have a mac a and let's suppose i
develop a program
on my mac and then i go to work and i
think you know what i could actually use
this piece of software i could use this
code that i've written this program
i could use it on my work laptop as well
but at work i've got a windows machine
and these are two completely separate
types of machines one's a mac
one's windows now to you they might just
be computers and that's fair enough
they're just laptops or desktop machines
one's a mac one's windows but
fundamentally these are completely
different machines
a key part of that is that for example
if i use an application on a mac
for example adobe photoshop then i can't
use that exact same application on
windows
it's true that both mac and windows have
a version of photoshop which they can
both run
but that version is completely different
one has code
for mac the mac program code if you like
and one has code for windows
the windows program code and the actual
code that each installation file will
contain
is completely and totally different and
the reason for that is that these are
completely and totally different
machines
we don't just have macs and
windows-based machines
you can also have linux-based machines
so for example when we spoke about cloud
computing earlier on or if you look at
large-scale websites like amazon the
e-commerce site for example
you'll find that what powers those
websites are hundreds if not thousands
of these so-called server machines that
just means a computer without a screen
pretty much
just super fast hardware or electronics
inside to be able to power these huge
e-commerce applications you also have
those as well and again linux is a
completely different type of machine
than a mac or than a windows machine so
given that we've said that
if you have an application or a program
on one machine like a mac
and it's not possible to run it on
another machine like windows how does
java do this then
let's take a look inside and see what
happens so let's take a look
at actually what's inside the windows
machine
so inside that machine first off we have
an operating system and the operating
system is
foundational computer program if you
like which tells a computer how to run
and what i mean by that is that if you
didn't have an operating system on for
example a laptop or a desktop machine
then you wouldn't be able to load any
programs onto it you want to be able to
access the internet
you wouldn't even be able to switch it
on have it do anything meaningful you
just switch it on nothing would happen
that's because all computers need an
operating system installed on them which
is kind of like the super program of the
computer if you like which tells the
computer how to run
so for example it tells the computer how
to access files how to access the
network how to display stuff to the user
how to print to printers that kind of
thing that's what operating system does
we have three different types of
operating systems we have operating
systems for windows
mac and linux which is why we started
off with those three machines initially
so once you have an operating system
installed on your machine that means you
can actually start to run other programs
on it so for example on my windows
machine at work
i can run microsoft word edit some
outlines for a course for example
i can also have google chrome running as
well do some web browsing
maybe i have outlook as well to be able
to access email i can do all of those
three things
execute those three programs at the same
time thanks to this operating system
that we have
and also underneath the operating system
by the way is the microprocessor this is
the actual chip
inside the computer itself i've kind of
graded that box out because we don't
really need to know anything about the
microprocessor apart from the fact that
having an operating system means that
the three programs at the top microsoft
word google chrome and outlook they
don't need to concern themselves with
the different types of microprocessors
so in this way the operating system kind
of shields those programs away from the
much deeper complexity of the actual
chip inside the computer itself but in
addition to these programs if we're
looking at java we can also install
another program
and that's known as the java virtual
machine now the java virtual machine is
really where all the magic happens
because it's this jvm java virtual
machine it's the first acronym there
that allows us to run different java
applications
so looking at the jvm once you have a
jvm installed on a given machine
that means that you can run bus java
application on it you can run your other
java application on it
and again another java application on it
so the jvm gives us a facility then to
be able to run
java programs that's the key point here
now going back to these three computers
we saw
before you can have different operating
systems on them so if you have a windows
machine
you might have windows 10 on there
windows 8 windows vista windows xp
those are different versions of the
windows operating system if you're on a
mac like i am
you'll have mac os 10 and on linux
servers you're going to have something
like ubuntu
suse linux redhaw or fedora the key
point here though is that these three
machines
each have installed on them different
operating systems however
because each of these machines or
specifically each operating system
has a jvm available for it that's the
java virtual machine
special application we've just seen so
there's a jvm for windows
a jvm for mac and jvm for linux because
of this
that means that the java program that
you write can then run
on each one of these machines so this
means you can write your java
application
on a mac then run it on windows or you
can write the java application in linux
and run it on the other two machines
windows and mac it really doesn't matter
and that's really the power of this
so-called
wara or this bright ones run anywhere
the fact that java gives you the ability
to be able to
do that so you write the application
once in java and then it can run
anywhere you choose to put it
there are a few other rack rooms as well
which we'll just quickly go over we'll
get to see these a bit later on too
the first one is the jre this is the
java runtime environment
and this is basically effectively the
package that contains that jvm
so when we saw the jvm just now which
was sitting on windows linux and mac
that jvm actually comes as part of the
jre the java runtime environment
and that's the key there as well it's
the java run time environment because
you're
running programs but because it's the
java runtime environment that's where
you'd expect to find this jvm because
the jvm's responsibility is to run
those java programs we also have the jvm
which we've seen the java virtual
machine
yeah that's the thing that runs those
programs we've seen and we also have
bytecode as well
so bytecode pretty much is what the jvm
runs itself
it's kind of like the language that the
java program is turned into
which the jbm can then understand we'll
see this in a little bit later when we
look at compilation
but what i mean here is that jvm as a
program
which runs java programs needs to take
an input it takes an input file
that input file contains the programming
commands to tell the program
what to do for the actual program code
itself and that program code
that is bytecode packaged in the
so-called class files which we'll see
a little bit later on too so who creates
the bytecode but what creates the
bytecode is the thing called the
compiler
so just to recap we've got the jvm which
runs the java application
the java application is a file
called a class file that class file
contains bytecode
and the thing that produces the bytecode
is a thing called a compiler
so the compiler's job is to basically
take your java program
and convert it effectively into
instructions that the jbm can understand
it does this by taking the program you
write in the java programming language
and that's known as source code so you
write source code
the compiler takes that source code
written in the java programming language
converts it into bytecode in a circle
class file
and then the class file is placed as
input to the java virtual machine
and the java virtual machine executes
each instruction
inside that class file the bytecode to
actually do what you've
programmed to do now this might seem
like a whole lot of stuff to take in
and indeed it is so let's jump in now
and look at a tangible example let's
bring it down
from up in the air and actually look at
this process firsthand and see how we
actually compile
a java source file into bytecode itself
okay so let's jump in now
and see actually how we can compile a
java program our java source code using
the java compiler
or java c as it's also known i'm on a
mac
it's a program called terminal so let's
just see how this process looks
now first off don't be phased by the
fact that i'm typing some commands into
this big black window
when you actually do java programming
you don't have to do this so what i'm
about to show you is really the
nuts and bolts of what happens with java
when you're compiling a java program to
its bytecode but i'm just doing it for
demo purposes so you won't actually have
to do this
yourself so don't worry you won't have
to type these types of commands and it
may look complex but it really isn't i'm
just showing you actually the lowest
possible
level pretty much the bare metal kind of
like level or this java compilation
is all about now we can actually do this
in a text editor that's a small program
that allows you to type in text
and save it to a file without any
formatting so without any kind of bold
or underlying or italic
instructions in that file this is just a
nice simple way to be able to quickly
create a file
using a command and for the purposes of
this demo it's fine you won't have to do
this in general so don't worry about it
so that said if i make a new folder
demo and i'll go into that directory
and i'll quickly create a file with this
special command and i'll just call it
app.java
and what this means is that i can just
basically type in code here and it will
create a file which is going to be the
java file
which will then compile and then see
what actually the java compiler spits
out
so if i just type some java code here a
public class
app and then we're going to define a
main method underneath
this method public static void main
which takes so-called array
of string parameters this is the
standard method that you'll find in any
java program which is where a program
starts off
so-called entry point but again don't
worry if this looks complex for now
because we'll cover this a little later
down the line and then here i'm just
going to type in this instruction
which basically prints out hello world
to the screen
it's that system.out.printline you can
see that and just finish that off with
some closing curly braces and press ctrl
z to end that
you don't have to know what this code
means but just know if i clear the
screen
i print out app.java just know that this
code
is the simplest possible java program
you can write and it's a java source
file because it has
a java so called file extension in other
words this is the file name here app
but it's extension which is this thing
that starts with a dot
this is dot java it's a dot java
extension so this means it's a java
source file
so how we compile that is we use java c
java c stands for java compiler
and we pass that java file into this
program
so when we just write out a command like
this
obviously it means it's going to run
that program so now it's running the
java compiler program
we'll do in a second rather and it will
take us input anything that we put after
it so here we're saying app.java is
input into
java c which is the java compiler if i
then hit enter
see pause briefly then for a second and
that's because the java compiler was
actually taking this
app.java file and producing the output
file if we now look
you can do with this command the
contents of that folder that directory
we'll see that we have our original
app.java which we created which is this
file here
but we also have now another file which
is app.class
this is the class file that we spoke
about earlier on that contains the
actual byte code that's then runnable by
the jvm
so now that we have that bytecode class
file let's see how we run it on the jvm
so again let's have a look at what we've
got in the directory here we've got
java which was the program that we
started with that was our java source
file
we've got app.class which is the class
file the java c compiler produced is
what it output so it took in the
app.java source file that's the program
code that we wrote
and it converted that into app.class
which contains the bytecode that's going
to run on the jvm
so all we need to do to run this is we
have another command the command to
launch the jvm the jvm itself
is java so whenever you see java this is
the jvm
and if you see java c it's a java
compiler so this command here means run
the jbm
again we pass the input we want that
program to take and you might think we
put app.class
we don't we just put app and what this
does when we run it is it's going to
launch the jvm so the java virtual
machine is going to be running
and it's going to look for class which
is the main kind of unit of code in java
it's going to look for a class called
app inside this current directory so
because we have this app.class file here
it's going to find that execute the
bytecode which is inside it so if we run
this now
here we can see it's running hello world
so that might seem a little bit
technical
and like i say it's something that you
won't actually have to do you won't have
to go into a big black box
and type in those commands in the
terminal like i did but i just want to
do that so it gives you a good idea of
actually what's happening behind the
scenes
and it turns out there's a tool that can
do that for us really nicely which looks
good it's got
you know a proper window we've dropped
down menus and it's a proper application
in fact and that's called an ide but
we'll see that a little bit later down
the line when we write a program
in java that's the source code that
we're writing just to summarize that and
we can do that
as i say in a thing called an which
we'll see shortly and so the source code
is what we write
it's the source of our program that's
why it's called source code and that's
in java programming language and that's
converted into bytecode
as in this class file that contains the
instructions which are interpretable by
the jvm which is the java virtual
machine and as we've just seen
how we get from source code in java to
the bytecode in the class file is by
using the java compiler which is this
java c tool we saw
so that should give you a nice overview
of how the main components of the java
platform slot together
and just a sneak peek into how we can
compile and run java program
using the java compiler part of the jdk
and the java virtual machine which is
part of the jre but also bundled with
jdk as well
we're going to move a bit further and
we're going to see how we can actually
install the jdk itself onto our own
machines
so the jdk remember is the thing that
has java c which is the java compiler
which is the thing that takes our java
source code
and converts it to white code then that
byte code is then run on the jvm
which is the java virtual machine and
there's also a jvm which is bundled
inside the java development kit which is
the java command we saw as well
so let's jump in so in order to install
the jdk we need to do
four different things really first off
we need to work out which version of the
jdk we need to install
so that means basically we need to
download the right jdk so if it's
the jdk for windows download the windows
one the jdk for mac download the mac one
but even amongst the individual
operating system there might still be
some choices which we'll see next we
need to download and run the installer
this is a really quick process to do
it's literally just kind of double
clicking
so that'll be nice simple and
straightforward next we need to set a
thing called an environment variable
which is going to be called java
underscore home
now environment variables it might seem
it's getting very technical now it's
really not
it's basically just a way of letting
other
tools which work with java itself it's a
way of letting them know
where you've installed jdk2 and we do
that through creating this thing called
an environment variable which is very
simple to do and straightforward as
we'll see
it just basically makes a piece of
knowledge knowing where the jdk is
installed
just exposes it so that anybody or any
other applications rather
which are running on that machine and
take a look at the environment variable
access the path or location of where we
installed the jdk2
and finally of course we need to test
that it actually works so first off
let's look at how we can work out which
jdk version to install
so i'm going to do this on a windows
machine this particular demo
because that's probably the most popular
operating system with people who are
watching this course
so the first thing you need to do is to
find out if you're using a 32-bit
version of windows or a 64-bit version
of windows
really easy to find out just go down
here to the start menu
and go to the little cog which is
settings
and then go up to system and then if you
scroll down to the bottom
you'll see about if you just click about
it'll tell you about the system
and here you can see at the bottom it
says 64b operating system
x64 based processor so this tells us
that this particular system
is running windows 64-bit and also if
you notice you'll see this x64
here just remember that for a second
because we'll actually see this
in the version of the jdk that we want
to download anyway so we can close this
now
with the x so just go down here into
search box and we're just going to type
in internet explorer just the first few
letters i'll do as you can see
so here we've got internet explorer so
we'll just click this
and if we just type in here
java jdk download and you can see that
it's showing us here
the first link the primary link is the
one that goes to the oracle website
and this is basically for all of the
downloads so all the different versions
that you have with java
this is the page you can get them from
but we want to have a specific version
we want to go for java 8 and that's
because it's a lot easier for beginners
to
work with java 8 than it is to work with
the latest and greatest version which is
java 15.
if we click on java 8 jdk
accept cookies and so here we are on the
java 8 jdk download page so if we just
scroll down
you'll see here that the version we're
going to download is this 8u281
which is basically the latest version of
the java 8 version of the jdk
which is the one we're after and then if
we go a bit further down we can see
we've got linux here we've got macos
solaris and right at the bottom we've
got these two options here for windows
at this point we need to know whether we
have 32-bit version of windows or a
64-bit version of windows
so there are two different versions of
windows that you can have 32-bit and
64-bit and these are denoted by
x86 means 32-bit and x64
means 64-bit you wouldn't necessarily
expect that and this is actually a
reference to the
underlying microprocessor but just know
that the 64-bit version one has 64 in it
and the 32-bit one doesn't
so we've checked already on this
particular version of windows and we
know that it's a 64-bit version that we
need
because if you remember that's the x-64
that we saw before
so let's download the 64-bit version now
okay so if you just click on this
exit file and we'll just accept the
license agreement
clicking that check box
and then just click this download button
here
and so unfortunately when you download
the jdk you have to have an account with
oracle it's free to sign up
so if you don't have an account you can
create this use this create account
button down there
but i already have an account so i'll
just put my details in
and then just hit sign in
then you can see here now it says do we
want to save or run
so i like to save it to the downloads
folder then i can run it from there
afterwards i'm not worried about saving
the password either so i'll just click
not for this site
so now you can see it's downloading it
doesn't take very long to download it's
not that big to be honest
also i've got a pretty fast internet
connection as well almost there
runs a security scan and it says it's
completed which is good
so then if we hit this few downloads you
can see here that it's actually in this
downloads folder
you also hit this button here it'll open
up the downloads folder itself in
explorer
so i prefer to run it from there so if
we just kill this browser
and just this one too they want to run
it from here
so you want to right click and you want
to do run as administrator
that's important because it needs to
make some entries into the windows
registry which needs administrator
permissions
so if we just
so just click yes to this so you can
make changes to the system
now we're just going to click next here
then we go to the next screen and on
this screen we can see the items that
it's going to install
so it's going to install the development
tools also the source code of the actual
jdk itself
which is interesting to look at as well
although it's outside the scope of this
tutorial
but it's definitely useful to have a dig
into that at some point if you're
curious
as well we've got the jre which we'll
also install just so just accept the
defaults here you could customize
the folders if you wanted to but that's
fine we're just going to set the
defaults for now that's okay
just click next and then we can see it's
just installing
it's pretty quick to be honest copying
the new files across over
at this point here is offering to
install jre first as well so you just
click next to that also
and you just run through that part of
the installation procedure as well
again it's pretty quick
you can see here the job has been good
for 25 years as well so it's a really
it's really stable and rich platform to
work on
which is why it's so popular
at this point it's been installed so
just click close there so now at this
point if we go into
the c directory which is under this pc
we look inside this program files
directory under java
then we can see here now we've got two
folders jdk and jre
version 1.8 so this is basically the jdk
the java development kit
and this is the jre the java runtime
environment that we've spoken about
before
just quickly while we're on the topic
let's just have a quick look inside
inside the jdk
you'll find a bin sub directory
subdirectory means a directory inside a
directory
and these are all of the the tools if
you like which you have access to as a
java developer to help you write java
programs
but the main ones you're interested in
are java c which is the java compiler
we've seen
and java itself which is the java
virtual machine
now the next step we need to do is we
need to if we just go back out to that
folder above
we need to basically put this folder
here which is the folder where we've
installed the jdk to
we need to put this in this so-called
environment variable so let's see how we
can do this now
so first of all if i just double click
this
then i click into the address bar here
just go over here and just right click
and then click copy
so what i've done actually here is i've
just basically put the the contents of
this
so the director that's highlighted into
the clipboard because i'm going to use
it later
i can just cancel this out now and then
i go into
this one here this pc into properties
which is actually an easier way being
able to set this environment variable
and then if we go into advanced system
settings you can see here you click on
that
and then click into environment
variables now what we're seeing here
this is basically the set of environment
variables which are configured for this
particular system
so the concept of an environment
variable isn't just specific to java or
even specific to windows
it's a concept which is available in all
operating systems and it just basically
provides little place in memory the
programs can look in to get a piece of
data they need to share
in the case of the java tools that's the
jdk installation path and that's what
we're going to set now
but there are other ones too the most
important one being path itself which is
the one you can see here which we'll
come to in a second
but first of all let's create our java
underscore home so if i click new here
then go java underscore home if i press
tab
that gets me into the text box below now
if i just do
ctrl v paste it and you can see it's
here now now also if we just put that in
quotation marks the reason being is that
windows is a bit funny if you have
spaces in a path that's meaning the
actual descriptor of where where the
folder is which is this thing we're
looking at here it's a path
you can see here we've got this space
between program and files so just to
protect that
we basically put a quotation mark here
and a quotation mark there
then that kind of like packages it all
up if you will so if we just click ok
now
so now we've got java home set the final
thing to do is to double click on the
path variable to change that
we're going to add a new entry here
which is
java under score home with these
percentage signs at either side
and that basically means resolve this to
the actual value so java underscore harm
is the variable that's the name of the
piece of memory which holds that data
but to get what's actually in that piece
of memory we can put percentage signs
around it it's known as dereferencing
that variable
to get the actual value out and then put
backslash bin
and enter and the reason for that is
because remember we've just had a look
in the jdk directory itself and we then
had a look in the bin subdirectory we
could see all those tools
or by putting this in here adding it to
the path this is going to allow windows
to locate
those java tools for us so basically
whenever you enter a command
in a dos prompt which is something we'll
see in a second one of those scary black
windows which isn't that scary in fact
but it might appear so at first but
it's really not whenever you enter a
commanding day what actually happens is
windows goes through each one of these
folders in turn
look inside that folder to see if that
command exists in that folder and when
it finds whatever the command exists
then it will execute it
so we're just going to move this up
in this a few times that means that the
first thing first place that we're
telling windows to look is definitely
going to be in like this java home
directory java home pin directory rather
and the reason for that is because
unfortunately windows actually comes
with
jre to be able to execute java in the
browser and that's actually stored in
this path here
and by putting this java on the score
home bin before that it means that we're
going to get our version of java which
is part of the jdk which we've just
downloaded
so if we click ok to this and ok to this
and let's close some of these windows
we're going to go into the command
prompt this dos prompt
if you type cmd you'll see here we have
this command prompt tab
click on that now we're in a thing
called the dos prompt or that's now
known
the command prompt and it's called that
because it's prompting you prompting
meaning to ask
it's asking by virtue of that this
thing's flashing this curse is flashing
here
it's asking you for a command it's a
command prompt makes sense yeah
so if we type set j which is a command
and hit enter this is going to show us
the
environment variables which have been
set which start with the letter j and
you can see here we've got our java
underscore home environment variable
that we set
if we were to do set p
then we'd see all of the variables which
start with a p and the first one we can
see is path
and now we can see here that we've got
the java home
environment variable we saw before it
was being dereferenced by those
percentage signs remember
with a slash bin after it that means the
subdirectory inside there if we now type
in
java c for the java compiler and do
version
and we should get a message back which
says it's the 1.8 java compiler and the
reason we're doing version
is just it's a nice quick and simple way
just to verify that given command
has been installed properly which in
this case is java c and we can do the
same thing for java as well which is the
jvm
that means that we've got the jdk set up
correctly and just to double check that
as well
we just check the java version and
similarly we also have
the same version here so these two
versions match now one eight zero
zero eight one one eight zero two eight
one which is fantastic so here we've got
the java compiler and we've got the java
virtual machine
don't forget if we hadn't put that entry
would be first in the list then we
wouldn't have seen
um that version here because it would
have been picking up the java version
from this
one here instead anyway at this stage
we're all set up and we can actually
start to
develop java applications on this
windows machine
we're going to take a look at the ide
that's an integrated development
environment
that's basically a tool that you can use
to write compile
and run your java programs which no
programmer will ever be without
so let's jump in now there are two
different ides on the market currently
when i say on the market you don't have
to buy them or anything but i just mean
those that are available
to you in general to download now both
of these are free or at least have
versions that are free and we'll just
have a look at both of them now and
compare them so
the first one is eclipse the eclipse has
been around a really long time
it's from the eclipse foundation and
it's a really good idea to start off
with
the other one we've got as well is
intelligent idea
now intelligent idea actually has two
different versions that you can get
it's got a community edition which is
the free version and it's also got
another edition called
the ultimate edition that's a paid
product which typically
you'll find in corporate organizations
so in other words in corporates where
you have a professional
java development team if they're willing
to spend the money on the ide and the
developers
typically will find they're using
intellij idea now the difference between
these two
are that eclipse is really easy to use
it's great for beginners
it's got various features which make it
more suitable for beginners in my
opinion
like for example when you're programming
it will actually highlight errors as you
go along
by underlining them in red which we'll
see in a second and it gives you very
clear error messages which
kind of imply or kind of tell you pretty
much how you should fix your code
so it's great for beginners and it's
very easy to use as well professional
developers
it can feel a little clunky at times and
so a lot of professional developers tend
to prefer intelligent idea
and again that's for more advanced users
it's got much more power behind
it because it can also be a commercial
product with their ultimate edition
you know they've really made this
product into something which you'd
expect a proper
java developer power user to be able to
get their money's worth with
however that said intelligent idea it
kind of does things behind the scenes
which you've got to be careful about if
you're not a professional developer and
if you don't know what you're doing
and so it can kind of trip you up so
it's definitely for advanced users but
eclipse
clips is definitely the thing to start
off with and we'll see how to install
that shortly
so that's the one we'll start off with
here and we'll see how to do that in
just a moment
so let's have a look now and explore
actually what features an ide gives us
so the first thing an ide does is it
provides you the ability to actually
type in your programs
so just like for example you might use a
word processor like microsoft word
to type up documents or reports for work
or you might use a spreadsheet like
excel
to do your accounts or manage your home
expenses just like that as a programmer
as programmers we use an id to type in
our java programs
and this makes things much easier as
you'll see because of some key features
which an ide provides the main ones of
these are syntax highlighting
showing you the errors you've made
suggesting improvements to your code as
you go along
let's take a look so let's look at the
first of these items then so what is
syntax highlighting this is one of the
things that the id does for you so what
is syntax highlighting
okay so here's a chunk of code it's a
very simple piece of code in java it
might look complicated it's really not
and it basically defines class my app
which has one method in it which is the
main method
one and only method which is going to do
something and what it does is it's going
to print out the message hello world
now if you see this program in an id it
would actually have syntax highlighting
and that looks like this so basically
here you can see that it's colored in
some words it's given some color to the
words and those words
which appear to be in a it's kind of
like a maroon or a dark red
maybe purple depending on how your eyes
are but anyway these um these words
like public class public static void
those are basically
filled that way to signify that they're
key words they're reserved words by the
java language
so the use of this for example is if you
maybe for example misspell public and
miss out the eye
then it wouldn't color code that into a
maroon color and you'd also have
kind of a squiggly red underline as well
which is tell you that is wrong but
coloring words in this way
coloring the text in this way it just
gives you that extra kind of quick
visual guide the meaning or the cement
or so-called semantics of that word or
that keyword
now you can see we've got other stuff
which is still in black typically these
are going to either be class names
methods or types so here we can see my
app is the class name main is the method
name
and the string array there string with
the two square brackets that's a type
we'll see again the actual variable name
which the thing we're passing in these
args value
a bit difficult to see but that's
actually in a different color again
that's how you can tell or differentiate
inside that method between those two
curly braces
you can see immediately whether you'd be
working on a variable which is passed
into the method
against a variable which is outside the
method for example you'll also see as
well
on the third line in where we've got the
system.out.printline we can see we've
got
the out is italicized it's in italics
and it's also in blue
that denotes that that's a static it's a
member which is a bit advanced now but
it's just another
way they can visually give you a bit of
help and inside you can see we've got
the string which we're passing into
system.out.printline which is a command
that
prints something to the screen you can
see we've got we're passing in that
string
in quotes and we can see it's color
coded that a nice bright blue for us
so we can immediately tell where the
strings are in the method as well that
might not seem that useful
but the more complex your programs
become you really get to be able to kind
of
see the code better with these kind of
features but you won't tend to notice it
too much when you start out though
so how does it show errors then i mean
that's probably the most important thing
you care about if you're a beginner
so here's an example so this is eclipse
and here we can see we've got the main
method we've got this application we saw
before and here we've got a class
so it says public class myapp and you
can see it's got a red underline
underneath my app
and there's a red and a circle to the
left of that the line numbers
and if you look beneath there you'll
also see the same red circle with an x
in it
and it says java problem is one item it
says syntax error untoken myapp
it says a left curly brace expected
after this token so you can see
here it's actually telling you what to
do it's telling you that after my app
which is the word it's underlined in red
it's expecting that you're going to put
this opening curly brace and in fact the
minute you put that open curly brace
the red x would go the red underline
would go and the problems would you see
there in this java problems
section that list that would also go as
well and be clear so there's one way it
can show you that things are not quite
right and you'll see red x's
everywhere contextually where that is so
if you see on the left hand side for
example this is basically the project
structure
you can see the deepest level is
myapp.java and then above there you've
got
app which is the package that's in the
package is just a folder for a class
inside java and then above there you've
got source main java which is the
folder which contains the actual java
code itself above there you've got app
which is the name of the actual project
again as soon as you fix it those would
go so the next thing we've said that it
gives you suggestions
which are going to help you out along
your way and this is really useful for
beginners so let's take a look at this
now as well
so now we've got a different id this is
intelligent idea now which we're looking
at
and just incidentally as well you can
still see we've got this red underline
here
so you can see in the main tab here
where it says app.java we've got a red
underline
and we also have it in the left hand
project pin as well and that's because
at the point
the exact instant where we're
programming in this particular program
the syntax is incomplete because we've
got system dot then we don't have
anything after that and that's not valid
syntax it's not a so-called
valid statement a statement is basically
the smallest unit of code that describes
what you want to have
happen and that can either be assigning
a value to a variable
or it can be invoking a method calling a
method on either a class or an object or
one of those things
so where this help comes in then is
actually where you're typing when you're
actually typing out the code
at certain points the id will offer you
suggestions as to what you might want to
type
so for example when i type system with a
capital s that's referring to the class
system which is inbuilt into java it's a
class that we get for free
with the jdk the jdk comes with hundreds
of different classes
you can use to do various different
things the system class is one of the
most basic or foundational classes that
you can use and when we do system
dot that dot signifies that we're going
to do something
on that system class or connected with
that system class
specifically we're going to access
something on the system class and we can
either
choose to access a data member so if
that class has
a variable inside of it which holds some
data sold some value or maybe an object
or whatever
we can access that we've seen that
before with system.out
out is actually a variable inside the
system class which stores a reference to
a thing called the print stream
which is basically the way that we can
print characters out
or print data out to the to the display
if you like
but in addition to being able to access
data with the dot we can also
invoke methods with the dot so here we
can see when we're doing system
dot we have several different methods
which we can choose to call
so the first method for example in this
box which appears below in this drop
down it automatically appears by the way
you don't have to do anything you just
as soon as you type dot this will appear
and you can see we've got a method set
property which takes a
key and a value we've got another method
array copy
which takes some other things got a
method current time millies
method console clear property that that
kind of thing what these methods do now
are not interesting to us but the main
point is that as soon as you hit that
dot
then the id offers you options for what
it's sensible to call at that particular
point that's a key point though it's not
just offering you any old stuff
it's actually offering you things that
would only make sense to call actually
there
but when the id offers you either
suggestions like this
or code fix suggestions they can also
fix code for you as well which is pretty
handy
or if it offers you the ability to
generate code to actually program
certain aspects of the code for you
which is also something else it can do
and by the way all of these things
together make a developer's life so much
easier
you actually think programming is pretty
difficult but when you look at the power
of an ide and what it gives you and the
amount of stuff it does for you
automatically it's actually not that
difficult
to do programming to be honest but
anyway the main point is that it also
takes into account the context
of where you're actually coding at that
moment in time to be able to offer
sensible suggestions as to things you
might want to do
and furthermore as you actually type out
the method if i started to type for
example
supposing i was going to go for the word
console for the method console
i would type the c and what would happen
then is it would automatically filter
that drop-down box
to just have the methods which start
with c so it would be clear property
console and current time millis which
appear
then i type oh so now i've got system.co
then it would just say console and at
that point then when it just says
console i can hit enter
in intellij idea or its tab in eclipse
and it would type out the rest so type
out the remaining letters
for me as well we'll also immediately
put the parentheses there for me so
those brackets and if i typed a method
which actually wanted to take anything
she was designed to pass in any input
parameters it would also tell me
what it's expecting so for example if i
was invoking the array copy method
as soon as the left parenthesis is put
in so the opening bracket it would come
up and say okay
what's your object source for example we
don't need to know what the actual array
copy method does
as it happens it just copies arrays as
you might expect those are those groups
of
things of the same type we saw before
like when we saw a string array actually
like we can see the string array above
these square brackets the point is an id
gives you all of these
really useful and helpful functions
along the way so it actually makes
developing programs
much easier you don't have to type you
know every single character painfully
piece by piece
that kind of stuff it does it all for
you and even if you for example put in
a left curly brace so an opening curly
brace and hit enter
it will also put in the closing curly
brace as well so you don't have to worry
about that
little things like that it'll also
indent the cards so you can see here
that online three we've got
the declaration line for the method and
you can see it's indented in other words
it's put space
to push it in from the left there that's
so we can see that visually that's a
method
and similarly inside the method on line
four when we're starting to write a
collection of statements which would
comprise this method we can see that
again it's indented it
and that means that visually we can see
now that any statements or any lines we
have from
line four which are inside of these
curly braces
they're going to be very kind of
visually clumped together or grouped
together
so that we know that's the
implementation of that method yeah
that's another thing that an idea will
do for you
the other thing an ide allows you to do
is to actually compile your code
so just like before when we did the
quick demo and we were compiling the
java code using java c
in the terminal window on the mac and
remember java c then took that java
source code
compiled it and turned it into java byte
code which could then run on jvm
but when you use an ide this is done
automatically for you and not just for
one file
for multiple files that might comprise
the project and typically what you'll
find
is that an ide will actually compile for
you continually as you're actually
developing the program
highlighting any errors along the way as
well and to just incurred improvements
you might want to do
now typing your program in and compiling
it is all well and good
but of course you need to actually run
the program as well and that's another
feature that an id
allows you to do to actually run your
program which is sometimes known as
executing your program and usually in
doing this it'll also show you inside
the id
itself any output that the program
returns which is also very useful to
have everything in one place
and finally one of the best features of
an id in my opinion is the ability to
actually debug a program
so as programmers we write program code
and obviously we're writing primary card
because we're assuming
what we're writing is actually going to
work more often than not it doesn't work
or at least if it doesn't work
completely there might be a few issues
with it which we've got to try and fix
and the best way of fixing does is
actually to run the program in
slow motion it's the best way i can
think about describing it this is what
you do pretty much when you're debugging
your program
it allows you to go through what's known
as step over each line of program code
as it's been executed
then along the side of it you can
actually see what's happening to the
other areas of your program
so how do you use an id what does it
actually look like when you're
programming properly for real
putting together a real program well it
looks like this first of all you're
editing the card
so you're inside the ide and you're
typing in the program code
which you think as a programmer is going
to do what you want it to do that's the
first thing you're going to do you're
going to edit the code
and then afterwards at some point you're
going to compile the code or build it
now with eclipse it does this
automatically for you as you go along
so it's always compiling code for you
automatically but if you use intellij
idea for example
you actually have to trigger this
because you're in control of when you
want it to do the compile
or to do the build itself but
nevertheless you're typing away
and in the case of using eclipse it's
compiling the code as you go along
this means that at some point you're
going to see some errors so unless
you're doing everything completely
perfect from scratch
you're going to see some errors like
those squiggly underlines we saw the red
underlines and the red crosses that kind
of stuff
and when you see those errors of course
you're going to have to correct them so
that means you're going to go back
you're going to edit your code again
when i say go back you don't physically
go anywhere or return anywhere you're
still just inside the ide so you're just
typing things out in eclipse
but you're just happening to notice red
or red crosses red underlines or
whatever
which is showing you so-called
compilation errors in other words
problems with your program that you have
to address because it's not compiling
and that's happening because the
compiler the java c compiler is doing
that for you behind the scenes so then
you re-edit the code to fix those errors
and then at some point of course
you get to the point where you have no
more errors you actually have the
complete code which comprises your
program
and at that point you're done because
then you can finally run the program
itself
so that's pretty much what we go through
as programmers and we're doing this
process of programming
coding so now we know what an idea is we
know what features it's got and we know
how to use it
let's jump in now and install eclipse
which is the best idea you can use if
you're a job a beginner let's jump in
so if we go to internet explorer again
this time if we type in eclipse
here we can see we're at the website for
eclipse.org the first thing that pops up
and we're just going to download eclipse
id
i'll just hit the download button here
and again you've got a choice of which
operating system you're going to use
we're on 64-bit windows so here we can
see
this x86 64 which means it's compatible
by the way for both 32-bit and 64-bit
versions of windows
that's fine click that
and then we'll just hit download
again same kind of thing we're going to
save it
it doesn't take too long to download as
well
now we can see it's completed so if we
just open go to open folder we can close
this now
we can see here we've got the eclipse
installation now if we double click this
because we set that java underscore home
environment variable before
eclipse now knows where to pick java up
from and how to run
so you've got different options here
we're going to choose this one
and we just install
accept the agreements and now it's
actually downloading
that particular version of the eclipse
ide onto your local machine
and it might take a while to download
but it's fine
you can see now it's downloaded so if we
just do launch
notice as well it's also created a
shortcut there on the desktop as well
the first time it launches it might take
a little bit longer that's fine
we'll just accept this as the default
for now click launch again
and now here we are we're inside eclipse
just close that
so this is the eclipse welcome screen
and you can just hide this
and close this panel here and then at
this point we're all set up we've
installed eclipse the ide for java
and we're all ready to start creating a
new java project now you know all about
ides
and as you can imagine programming isn't
actually as bad or as complex as people
would imagine when you've got a tool as
powerful as that at your disposal
and we'll be seeing how to use an id in
the next video
we're going to look at java code in
detail for the first time so we're going
to start with
an overview of the key constructs those
are the key kind of
things you have to write to be able to
develop your java programs then we're
going to pull it all together
by having a live coding session in
eclipse to program a very simple program
in the ide let's jump in so let's just
take a look at actually what's inside a
java application then
in other words what are the components
we'd expect to find inside a java
program itself
so first up we have a class definition
and this basically is the main
unit of code that you create in java so
when you write a java program
pretty much you're writing these classes
which can then be assembled into objects
and then how the actual program works is
that these objects can have methods
invoked on them
a method is like a chunk of behavior
which you want the object to do
that method typically will cause an
interaction with another object
or it'll cause the object itself somehow
change its state in other words to
change the data that's actually inside
the object
so this might seem a little bit abstract
for now don't worry about it too much
don't forget that we're just actually
looking at what the high level pieces
are for now
and we'll go into actually how they work
a little bit later on so first up here
we have a class
and how you declare a class in java is
that you have to use this kind of syntax
here
so when we say syntax we mean basically
the sequence of words you've got to use
and whether you have to use any special
symbols like for example you can see
here we've got
this kind of like curly bracket thing
this is known as a curly brace
so you've got a left brace there at the
top after the word myapp and you've got
a
right curly brace at the bottom you can
see that's basically the syntax
the combination of words and symbols
used to define the class the java
compiler just don't forget as well as
the java compiler that java c
program we saw it's going to be
responsible for taking the source code
right
taking the java code that you write and
then producing a bytecode file out of it
and because of this it needs to follow a
very well-defined format of how you
present things
in other words you need to speak its
language you need to speak the language
of the compiler
and that's basically what you're doing
when you're programming in java you're
speaking the language that the compiler
understands
writing your program in java which can
then be compiled and into bytecode and
another jvm
so yeah so here we can see we're
creating a class the class is name all
classes have a name
and the name of this class is my app so
you can call a class whatever you like
to call it it's entirely up to you and
typically you'll call a class give it a
name that is
based on the actual thing that you're
modeling and in this case
a name like my app for example would
expect maybe this is like a class which
would
be the kind of starter class if you like
which starts off your java program
so in other words it's kind of like
think of it as like the the main class
or the top level class if you like after
all java programs need to start
somewhere
and they start with a method which
contains the behavior to start the
application
and that method needs to be defined
ultimately inside a class
so we can imagine that this class here
myapp is a class which effectively
contains your application okay
now how we actually define a class my
app is we use the classes name which is
my app as you can see there
and we can see it's got a capital m and
a capital a that's because
in general with java when you're
defining class names you capitalize the
words that make up the name of the class
that's why it's capital m and capital a
and immediately before this we've got a
word which is class
and that's because in java when you're
finding something you have to tell the
compiler what it is you're defining so
you're defining a method
or a class or a variable whatever else
it might be we'll come across these
things a little bit later on but for now
just know that to create this class
you must at least have word class then
followed by the name of the class
then of course inside the class itself
you need to actually give the code
which you want to go inside the class so
in other words you need to give the
methods which define the behavior of the
class
is to find those inside the class and
you also need to define as well
the data that it's going to hold so a
class in general in java it holds
methods
which will tell objects what you want
them to do and it holds data
which will tell objects data or the
states if you like which you want them
to hold and you need to wrap all of
those
inside these curly braces which you can
see here so a classical relation in java
at least needs to have
class in the class name and an opening
curly brace
then the code you actually want to put
in the class and a closing curly brace
now you'll also see this word at the
front which is public
and that's because in general most
things that you declare in java can have
what's known as a visibility modifier
that's just a fancy way of saying how
visible that thing
in this case the class is going to be to
other items or other things
inside your program and with this word
here public it means that basically
everything inside the scope of the
program will be able to see
the class myapp we'll see this a bit
further down the line when we cut a
quick class up in an ide
but yeah that's basically how you
declare classes inside java
next up we have these method
declarations so as we've said in java
classes contain
methods and a method basically is a
program code
or rather it contains the program code
of something you want to have happen
so here for example we've got a method
called greet again methods have names
just like classes do
and again we can see we've got the
opening curly brace and the closing
curly brace
so as you might imagine inside these two
things
you have the actual code that you want
to execute whenever this grease method
is called in other words the thing you
want it to actually do
which is also known as the
implementation of the method and you'll
see also again
that at the front there we've got this
keyword again called public
so by the way as well we have these
things called keywords so keywords are
basically
special words that you use in java which
signify something special to the java
compiler
as we've said before we've got public as
a keyword and public means that any
other items in the program can access
this particular thing which in this case
is a method
that means that if i have 10 20
different classes inside my java program
all of those classes will be able to see
this greet method
that's one key word void is another
keyword which we'll get to in a second
and we have class as well which we've
just seen before which is the keyword
used to declare a class
so i come into this void and the
brackets which you can see here so
after greet after the name of the method
which is greet
we've got these opening and closing
brackets called parentheses
and what you normally find inside these
parentheses are you find the input
parameters
so in other words the inputs that this
method can take so a method in general
you want it to do something and in order
for it to do something sometimes it
might need to take actually more often
than not
it might need to take some specific
input some specific parameters we call
them so you'd place them
inside these parentheses now if you just
see parentheses on the run with nothing
in them
then that actually means quite logically
there are no inputs to this particular
method
so here this method called greet it
doesn't take any inputs in other words
it doesn't need to have any values
has to it to be able to do its job the
reason is because for example you can
imagine
it would just display hello world on the
screen and if it just displays hello
world on the screen
it doesn't need to have an input
conversely if you wanted it to take an
input
you could for example sin a so-called
string which is a piece of character
information
in other words a word pretty much and
that string might be called name
then you could say hello and then the
person's name so you could use that
so-called variable to be able to access
the value that's passed to this method
we'll get to how we call methods also
known as how we invoke methods a little
bit later on and we get into the demo of
how we can cut some java
and but for now just know that the
parentheses enable you to pass the
method the inputs of that method
so the parameters that it takes now if
you pass things in
obviously there's a chance you might
want to pass things back out and you can
pass something back out
by the word which goes before the name
of the method and that's that special
void word we see here
so a void in this case is a special word
special keyword which actually means
don't return anything so again the case
of the greet method which is just going
to display hello on the screen
it doesn't need to return anything it
doesn't need to pass anything back to
another method that might have called it
because methods can call other methods
that's how java programs work to get the
job of the program done
and in this particular case because it's
just printing single thing which we'll
just define inside the method itself
which is this hello world couple of
words
it doesn't need to return anything to
anybody else so then you'd use this
keyword void
now if you wanted to return something
else for example you wanted to return
the greeting itself
then you could replace void with the
actual so-called return type
that's basically the type of the thing
that you're returning you could say
public string greet that would mean that
this method returns a string
character data we saw before that's a
string of alphabetical characters
basically
or maybe you want it to return something
else you could return an int for example
which stands for integer that could be
just a number you're returning
you might return a date if you're doing
some kind of logic to manipulate the
date on the calendar that kind of thing
i could return an object as well so you
can return choose to return whatever you
want basically
and also similarly with inputs you can
also choose to pass in
whatever you want so again objects hints
those are numbers
strings that kind of thing whatever you
want to pass in that's fine you just
separate
them with commas that's how method
declarations work then we've got
variable declarations
so here's a variable declaration here
now variable is a place
inside the program which is kind of like
a storage area you can think of it as
being a box
and inside that box it's going to hold
some piece of data some value that you
want to assign to this variable in other
words put inside the box
so here for example we've got string
recipient name and you can imagine that
might have a value assigned to it which
is
your blogs for example maybe this might
occur if you were writing some
logic to process an order for example on
a website like amazon you imagine amazon
might have some kind of order processing
java code there
you could also store number and this is
an integer it's a whole number so
number of items for example you might
call num items and here by the way as
well you can see
that the convention that means the
pattern or the rules you have to stick
to
the convention we're using to use as the
name for the variable
is slightly different from that with a
class so here it doesn't start with a
capital
it starts with a lowercase that's nice
because it means that we can just by
looking at two items
last name or a variable name we can
quite easily tell if we're working on a
variable
or if we're working with a class that's
the reason for that
and finally you might have shipping
address for example and that could hold
a reference to
that means the actual type of the thing
that's inside the box that's the thing
which comes first
so in all of these cases you'll see the
first word the keyword which you have
is basically the type of the thing
you're storing in the variable so string
recipient name so we're going to store
characters in their character data our
words
are for numeric characters in num items
here we're storing in a number
an integer okay so that means that we
can't for example assign a person's name
to num items
because that will fit inside that box
that box is just designed
for numbers it's not designed for
strings similarly recipient name we can
assign the number 2042 to recipient name
because it's expecting characters
character data now the real power of
object oriented programming which java
is based on
is that you can then start to work at
higher levels you can start to compose
things together in others build them
together with building blocks so here we
can see we've got shipping address
now shipping address its type of the
thing that it holds
is an address right and an address can
be a class which is defined elsewhere in
the program
and that address might also have other
items in it it might have a string
which is address line one another string
which is address line two
maybe it might have a zip code which is
of type zip code and zip code itself
could be a class
and maybe inside the class zip code it
also has in addition to the actual
numbers and letters that it's holding
the data that it's holding just like
we're defining data here
in addition to that it might also have a
method which can validate a zip code
passed in so when you try and create a
zip code for example
out of a string so you pass it a zip
code in my on creation of that string
also invoker method to make sure that
that string is valid in other words it's
a valid zip code
and you can put that kind of logic in
these objects in these classes which
we'll see
now where do you define variables you
can define them either inside a method
or alternatively as we can see here you
can define them inside a class
and when you define them inside a class
you typically find them grouped together
like this
and you'll also see another modifier
visibility modifier or access modifier
which we haven't come across yet and
this is private so just like we've seen
public before which basically means that
anything in the application can see that
other thing we also have this other
keyword called private
and that means that only the thing that
holds these variables
can see those variables for example if
these were in a class which is called
order so imagine we've got some kind of
order class which we've created
to hold the information when somebody
makes an order on amazon
for example if we were doing some kind
of website like amazon then maybe we
want to have the recipient name in other
words who's going to receive
the order the number of items how many
things they're actually ordering
and the actual shipping address so where
we need to send it we'd have other
things as well of course
like for example the thing that needs to
be sent that's obviously not on here
but this gives you an idea now when we
have these items of data which are
inside the order class
we're going to keep them private so that
it's only the order class who can
operate
on these values and the reason for that
is just keep things nice and tidy
because
if these were public it basically means
that any other class in the application
could start meddling with and
interfering with these data values
and then you can risk the so-called
integrity of the program so a nice thing
about object-oriented design
object-oriented programming
is that you can so-called encapsulate as
the word here
encapsulation encapsulate the data
that's inside an object inside the
object itself
you can think of this pretty much being
like order is like a box and it has
three other boxes inside string ins and
address recipient name number of items
and shipping address
it's only the order class itself which
can see and operate on these values
we have two items to objects or classes
that is we have data members which we
can see here that's actually holding the
state
of a given object but we also in
addition we have methods as we've seen
as well
so you could imagine basically an order
class might have some behavior attached
to it which we've programmed
which we call dispatch and so you can
imagine that at some point in the
program
another object perhaps when we've
actually received the cache or entered
our credit card details or rather
receive the credit card details from the
user
we then invoke the dispatch method and
inside the dispatch method we'd have the
code
to actually send the order and maybe
that might return back something as well
so for example it could return an order
reference which might be just one big
long number
so here we can see another so-called
data type which is long which basically
means like a number which is
much bigger than you can hold inside an
integer don't worry about that too much
for now the different types you have in
java but just know that classes
have two things they have data members
and they have methods
and they're defined like this so going
back to the idea before we have
a first class or a primary class or the
main class if you like which actually
starts an application
how does that work then well that works
with something called a main method
so here we can see a main method and it
looks a little bit more complex than the
format of the other methods that we've
seen
but it actually follows the same syntax
so here we can see the name of the
method is just before these parentheses
it's called main that's the name of the
method inside the parentheses we can see
the input parameters to that method
which is always the same it's basically
a group of strings this group is called
an array it basically means they can
pass in multiple
strings or multiple character data to
that method that's what those two
square brackets mean after the string
word now inside the code of the method
if we wanted to access those
we'd access them by using the word args
which is basically the name of that
array that we can use inside the method
code to be able to access the inputs
that have been passed in now
to the left of main we've got void which
we've seen that means it doesn't return
anything
and indeed there's nothing that it could
return there's nowhere it could return
any data to because it's just
going to be invoked from when we run the
jvm like we've seen before
when we do java and then the class name
what the jvm does is it basically looks
for that class
looks for a main method inside that
class which is this one and then runs it
but because nobody's calling it besides
the operating system or beside the jvm
or rather the jvm he doesn't need to
return anything so it returns void
right at the very front we can see it's
public that means that anybody can call
it which is useful if you want other
classes to be able to
kick off the program but in general you
don't really care about that but
nevertheless it's public
it makes sense for it to be public
because it's the main method and finally
in between public and void we've got
this other method called static
and what that means as a special keyword
again that basically means that
this method can be invoked it can be run
but it doesn't have to be invoked or run
against an object it can just be
invoked as is against the actual class
which contains that method
we'll see that later on but don't worry
about that for now and you can see as
well of course we've got the
implementation of the method we have
between the opening and closing curly
brace there as well
so let's see how we can put it all
together into a java program now by
jumping over to the id and putting it
all together
yeah let's jump in now and give you a
quick demo of how we can actually use
the id so we're going to use eclipse for
this
and it's basically just to give you a
kind of a kind of an idea kind of a walk
through basically of what typing some
java code into an id looks like
so we'll see how we can type in code
features of the id how the builds
occurred how it compiles it how we can
run the card too
afterwards we'll have a look at how we
can actually debug code let's jump in
oh by the way i'm on a mac for this and
but don't worry though because
actually as it happens eclipse and
intelligent idea they're both
applications which are programmed in
java and so because of this
it means that they're pretty much the
same to use on both platforms you
shouldn't have any difficulty in
understanding be showing you this and it
clips on a mac
if i jump in now and i just click this
eclipse
so we'll just accept this as the default
that's fine just to launch
so if we just double click this maximize
it and get rid of this screen
and here we can see we're in eclipse and
here we can see we're actually in the
so-called eclipse workbench
so you'll see here that in the main pin
we don't have any program code yet
that's because we don't have a program
specifically we don't have a project in
fact
which is where we actually put our
program code in order to write a program
you need to have a project
so that's the first thing we're going to
do so let's jump in and create a project
together so there are different types of
projects you can see over here
i'm just going to go into this one and
create the simplest possible type of
project
java project if i go down to next
project name we'll just call it my app
we can accept the defaults on here
so just go down to finish and it's going
to ask us if we want to open up an
associated perspective
this is basically a layout of the
windows which defines pretty much what
tools you want to see
when you want to have them positioned so
i'll just do remember my decision
and then do open perspective and now
we're in this so-called java perspective
which means we can actually start doing
our programming so if we go over to here
into package explorer
double click this this actually shows
you the project itself
so the project so far just has two
things associated with it it has
source folder which is where we're going
to put our program code and it has
this jre system library this is
basically saying which version of java
you're going to use
so i want to create a class which is
going to be the main program
so i right click here and i go into new
and i could just go straight for new
class i could do that but instead what
i'm going to do is i'm going to create
a package first and a package is
basically kind of like a well-named
folder
in which you can group different source
files that's not too important to
understand now but in general with java
it is something that you need to do
where you basically place classes
into packages just keeps everything nice
and organized
so i'm going to give a package name
of com.java easily
got demos i'll do for now and then i'm
just going to hit enter
i don't have to use the mouse to click
this finish button if it's already
highlighted blue like this i can just
hit enter and it saves me from having to
move the mouse over there
so enter just picks out the default
person that's currently highlighted
effectively clicks it for you
and by the way as well packages in
general they follow what's known as the
reverse
domain convention that basically means
that you take the domain name of the
company that you work for
in my case it's java easily.com and then
you reverse that it'll give com.java
easily
then after that you can put whatever you
like which makes sense to your
organization
just to be able to group the different
classes that you write so here this
explains com.java easily.demos
so now if i just right click in here now
i can create the class i go to new class
and we can see here it's going to create
it in the source folder it's going to
create it in this package here that
we've just created
now i just have to give the name of the
class so i'll call it my app
and also there's some extra options here
which we don't really care about apart
from this one over here
we tick this it's also going to create
that standard main method which we said
before kicks off the java program so
we'll just do that
and click finish now we can see we've
got our first class
my app where we can put our program code
and we put it inside the main method
and at this point this is a fully
working program doesn't do anything
because we haven't actually got an
implementation we haven't got anything
rather we haven't given any instructions
inside here so let's just plug in a line
now just to print out our message
so to do this we use the system class
which is part of jdk
you'll see here that it's in the
java.lang package
so that's one thing to know about java
any classes which are in the java.lang
package
they get what's known as imported
automatically for you
which means that you don't have to
explicitly declare that you want to
bring
some class in to use it now we haven't
looked at imports basically if you want
to use
class from another library typically
what you'll do is between the package
statement at the top on line one
and the class declaration on line three
you'll use an import statement
and the import statement will be
something like for example import
java.util.list for example if you wanted
to
reference a list from the java.util
package the java comes with a whole heap
of different classes
which are inside various packages as
part of the jdk you can have all of
those at your disposal as well
but for now just know that we've got the
java.long package which has effectively
been auto imported for us
anyway so then i do system dot you can
see here this is the
compiler giving us helpful suggestions
so if i look in here if i scroll up
you can see it's not just one method or
field it's given us it's given us a
whole heap of them a whole different
array of them
these are all the different methods or
fields these variables inside the class
that i could actually access now
so for example we're going to do this
one here
which is out so i could either type out
like that and as you can see as i typed
each character
maybe just back up a little bit i type
each character so i type the o first
you can see there that it's actually
matching
and filtering the list based on that
specific letter
i do you next now you can see it's got
two options it can
suggest for me i want this one also as
well another really nice thing in
eclipse
you'll see on the right hand side there
of the method and field suggestions
they've got this kind of like
documentation panel and this is actually
showing you the so-called
javadoc that's the java documentation
for this particular field
on the system class so it's really nice
that you get this kind of help
specifically when you're starting out as
well so you can then go over for example
you just have a read of it you can
scroll up and see
what it's telling you you can see those
same there's some other methods that you
could also
choose to look at as well if you wanted
to we're not going to look at this in
detail now but just know that it's there
to help you and it's again it's another
one of these nice
aspects of eclipse you have which again
makes eclipse in my opinion
the best id for beginners to start out
with that said if i hit enter
now i've got this system.out reference
which is a reference to the print stream
which enables us to be able to write
a message to the display now if i press
another dot
here you can see we've got the same kind
of thing again only this time
instead of it showing us like you did
before methods or fields which were
available on the system
class now of course we're not accessing
the system class anymore
now we're accessing the print stream
because out which is a field inside the
system class
the actual type of that the print stream
so that's how it works in java pretty
much
whenever you have a dot it's the thing
immediately to the left which is being
referenced
and again when you press the dot you can
either access fields on the class or
object
or methods on the class or object
another method i want is called
print line so if i start typing p r
i n t l n
you can see here we have a whole heap of
methods which all appear to have the
same name
and that's because they're the same
method but in java you can specify
method multiple times with each method
declaration accepting different types of
input
and that makes the method very flexible
so for example here you can see we can
choose to pass in
i use my arrow keys an
integer that's the type for those whole
numbers we saw so numbers like
3 17 4072 that kind of thing
oh we could pass in a string so that's
why we have a message which is in
quotation marks
so it's a very flexible feature of java
and it's known as method overloading
if i now press enter then you can see
it's automatically selected that
particular method for me
it's also put the parentheses round as
well and now it's also saying okay we'll
give me a string which you can see there
above
if i just put quotation mark hello world
the quotation mark and at this point you
can see that we've no longer got any
red underlined squiggles squiggly
underlines nor do we have any of those
red crosses
in the circles that's because now this
particular class is valid java code in
other words
it can be compiled down to bytecode and
then executed on a jvm
if i move this cursor away you can see
as soon as i moved it to the right
by the way i'm using the arrow keys do
this so your left arrow moves you one
way
right arrow moves you the other way so
as soon as i moved it to the right
because we were outside of those
parentheses then eclipse
notice that there's no point in giving
us that little helpful tip which told us
what it was expecting which was a string
so at this point we've got a valid
program now if i just save it
because we've got this star here which
means we haven't saved it so i'd do
command s on a mac
control s on windows just save that and
then if i
right click on here the class itself
and do run as java application
and then we'll see here we've got this
new tab which has popped up called
console
it says that the program is finished
that's what terminated means
and you'll see underneath we've got a
message a string that we passed the
system.out.printline
which said hello world so you can see
here a few things number one
it's allowing us to type in the program
code and with that it's giving a syntax
highlighting
showing us when we make errors and it's
providing helpful suggestions
number two because it ran the program
that means it must have compiled the
program down to bytecode
so it must have invoked the java c
compiler somewhere along the line which
we'll see in a second
finally number three is actually running
the program for us as well which means
it's passing that compiled by code the
jvm
we can see here in fact this is the
actual command that it used to that when
it launched a jvm now just to show you
as well
we actually do have last file which was
generated that's the bytecode don't
forget
if we go up to window and go to a new
view
we go down to navigator
and you can see here this is actually
showing us all of the files which are in
the project
so this panel here
this pane here is just showing us
basically the items that are relevant to
our source code it's just purely focused
on
showing us the relevant things it's
actually shielding things from us that
we don't necessarily need to see on a
day-to-day basis which is kind of good
because you can just focus on exactly
what you need to focus on which is the
actual
code and making that work but you'll see
we don't have for example
the myapp.class file which would expect
it is there
it's just in a separate subdirectory so
if we go down to the navigator view here
you'll see that this is the actual real
object structure with all of the files
and you'll notice that inside our source
folder we've got source
com java easily demos
java by the way that's one thing to bear
in mind as well that the package
that you place a class into actually
gets turned into a directory structure
like this so you can see this is like
comm
dot java easily dot demos which
corresponds to com
java easily the demos up there anyway
that's where the source file was
and similarly if we go into the bin sub
directory
we'll see the same structure so we'll
see com java easily
demos corresponding to com.java ease
little demos
because java classes in a specific
package compiled down to
class files which are in the same
package so therefore it has the same
folder structure
and inside there you can see we've got
myapp.class
which corresponds to my app.java here so
my update class my upload chart
so if i close these off and this one too
and you'll see there are also some other
files and folders there as well we've
got the project the class path
and our settings these are folders and
files for eclipse's internal use
we don't need to know about those for
now so if we just come out of this
and so we'll just see now how a method
works for example
so i can actually take this piece of
card here i can do this
i can actually do a special advanced
procedure which i'll give you a sneak
peek into
or refactoring so if i just right click
here
and i go down to this menu here refactor
and use this one here called extract
method if i click this
now what this is actually going to do is
it's going to take this statement out
or printing hello world and it's going
to push it into its own method
and replace it then with a call to that
method this is a great way how we can
first of all reinforce our understanding
of how methods are declared
but also we can actually see how they're
invoked as well how the method's
actually called
in other words this asking me to give it
a name so i'm going to call
method say greeting for example
and here you can see we've got these
access modifiers we were talking about
before you'll recognize private
and public earlier on in the course
we'll just leave it for private for now
that's fine
because we're only calling this method
from within this class
it's okay that it's private it'll still
be visible to the method from which is
called as we'll see
then here we can see we've got a preview
of the signature itself
and the method signature is just a fancy
way of saying what the method
declaration looks like
with all its combination of modifiers
return types
method name and input parameters so now
if we click on ok
you'll see that just like that we've got
a new method so this is how you actually
call a method you just basically use the
method name
then the two parentheses there which
matches the method name here
and the two parentheses here and here we
can see the method declaration itself
so if we rerun this now it shouldn't
change anything
just right click again go down to run as
java application
yeah it hasn't changed anything so
you're probably saying well what's the
point in rerunning it well the point of
rerunning it is just to make sure
that after we did that so-called
refactoring we're just rerunning it to
make sure we didn't break anything
because in spite of the fact that we
didn't actually have any red error marks
do we did that
it's still possible that we might have
some kind of errors or whatever
depending of course on how complex the
code refactoring you were doing actually
was
so let's quickly demonstrate now how we
can actually pass parameters so if i
just go up here
let's supposing i want to pass a
parameter here such that instead of
saying hello world
it'll say hello and then the person's
name in order to do that
let's put in a parameter here so we use
the type
of the parameter which is going to be a
string because it's going to hold
textual data so character data so
alphabetical characters
that kind of stuff and we give the
variable a name
which coincidentally will also call them
because that makes sense we're passing
in
the name of the person we want to greet
and once we've done that
we can delete this and replace world
with the variable that we passed him
if we pass in matt it would say hello
matt we pass in john it would say hello
john
and you'll notice over here we're
getting this red
wiggly underline again and the reason is
of course because we're not actually
passing a name now
because we haven't adjusted this method
call to take into account that we're now
passing a name here
and if we didn't know that give you
another demo of how helpful ideas can be
if we just click on this x over here
we can see that it's offering us some
ways to fix this situation
it's saying we can either add an
argument that means a has a parameter
to match the fact that the method takes
a string parameter
that's what we're going to do by the way
our alternative is saying you know what
you can actually change the method
itself
to remove parameter both of those if you
think about it would fix the situation
just press escape quickly just to
explain this if we pass in a parameter
here which is a string
it will match this which means it would
then work and remove that red x square
the underline
and similarly as well if we removed this
parameter here
then we'd have a method which doesn't
take any parameters that would also work
which would again
remove this squiggly underline and the
red x so both of those options are
perfectly viable
if we go back on again by clicking it we
see there's another option as well which
is to create a completely different
method which doesn't take a parameter at
all
and at this point you'd actually have
two methods with the same name
one takes a string one doesn't that's
the concept of overloading
i mentioned a few moments ago so yeah
all viable options which the id is
offering you
all easy to understand and simple to
digest as long as you read actually what
it's saying
and you'll notice as well that on the
right hand side where we saw the
documentation panel before
which gave us help documentation this
time we've actually got a potential
preview
of card that he could write for us now
he doesn't know who we actually want to
say the greeting to
whether it's matt or john so the best it
can work out and say whether that is
infer
the best it can infer which we usually
say the best it can infer is just to say
well okay
don't really pass anything past null we
won't go into null and what that is
it's outside the scope of this lesson
but it's one solution and similarly
as well if you click this one it's again
giving you a preview of what that would
look like
of course it hasn't fixed the entire
code because even if it did that it
removed
that name parameter you'd still then get
an issue here
maybe referencing something that hasn't
been passed in
but it's enough to give you an idea what
you might want to do and the where the
id would adapt to the card for you
so anyway we're going to double click
here now and as it promised it's put in
that null placeholder for us
which means that at least now the code
compiles now instead we're just going to
replace that null value
with my name for example and if you just
press escape afterwards
it loses that box highlight so you can
see the code a little bit better so now
if we
run the program and to run as
java application we'll see that he's
doing something else helpful because we
didn't save that before
there was a star there still now it's
saying oh do you want us to save the
resources for you as well you want to
save the source file
yes i do i'll even say always save the
resources before
launching so always overwrite and do
okay and now we can see it's saying
hello matt
so that's an overview of how you can
pass parameters into methods now to show
you the idea about debugging that we
were talking about before
we could right click and do run as that
will just run the program but i can also
do debug as i can debug the program
now before you do a debug now before you
launch the debugger
or rather the id when it's in debug mode
you need to set a thing called a
breakpoint
and that's basically where you want the
program to stop that is to stop running
at that specific point
so you can effectively take a look
around so if i go up to here for example
if i double click the margin just to the
left of the line numbers
let's say you set a breakpoint this
means that now
if i right click and do debug as
java application well first of all ask
me if i want to switch to perspective
i'll say remember my decision yes i do
go to the debug perspective
now this is going to change the windows
slightly and the panels that we've got
so then now this particular perspective
in other words this arrangement of
windows
and panels is geared towards debugging
so in other words like
looking through the card and actually
it's called stepping through the code
see everything that's going on just
notice the fact that what we've actually
got here now is
the program is suspended just before it
executes this line so this but it's put
this highlight in here
it's highlighted this line what that
means is i've stopped here just before i
execute this line before i
run this particular line or do this
method call in this case
and it's effectively saying what you
want me to do it's not going to do
anything unless we do something
at this point what we can do is we can
what's known as step
into the method so this is the say
greeting method
and it's calling this a greeting method
so if i go up here to
the run menu we'll see that the first
few
menu items here are effectively commands
that you can do at this point
so i can choose to do step into which is
f5 which will go into that method
or i can do step over which is f6 which
goes over the method
i'll just show you what those mean now
so if i click back here
press f5 you'll see that now
it's gone inside of this method call so
now it's inside this
method here which we have you'll also
see a few other things now as well
you'll see that in the right hand pin
we can actually see the variables that
are available now
so this method has a name variable which
is passed in
if i hover over it here it actually
tells me what that value is is matte
which is
really helpful and you'd only get this
in the debug view by the way because
this is now running
code it's not us programming it it's the
jvm running it now
you can see over here we've got variable
name it says matt
and then over on the left hand side you
can actually see
what's known as the call stack that's
basically showing us the sequence of
calls
that have been called it's kind of funny
but it goes from the bottom up
so it's saying basically the first thing
that it ran was
the main method in the my app class
which happens to take an array of
strings that's corresponds to this one
here the main method
in the my app class which took an array
of strings
it got to line six you can see here line
six which is this line here
and now it's at a breakpoint on line ten
in the say green ting method which takes
a string so here we've got the
segregating method which takes a string
and this is line 10 which is stopped at
and you can see
line 10 here line 10 here it's showing
you very accurately what's going on
so like before when we stepped into the
method if we had a method we wanted to
step into the code of
f5 instead we can press f6 now which is
step
over so when you step over something it
just goes to the next line
so if we do f6 now you can see it goes
to the next line
now if we do step over again you can see
it jumped out of that method because it
finished
that method there's nothing else it
needs to do there because it got to the
end closing brace that right hand curly
brace you can see there
but also notice what happened as well
the name variable which we had here
before
that's now gone that's because that's no
longer what's known as in
scope in other words it's not available
to us anymore because in this method
here there isn't a variable called nim
that was only in that method here and
only specifically for that method at
that specific
point in time but now that method's gone
and we can tell that method's gone as
well because if we look back over here
to the call stack
we no longer have this say greeting
method here we no longer have it on the
call stack
and in fact now we've progressed from
line 6 which it was before to line 7
which is this one
so finally if we press f6 to step over
this point there's no more code to run
the application's finished
terminated we've finished what's known
as our debug session
you can also do various fun things as
well when you're in a debugger for
example you can change
the values of things you can choose to
return from methods early you can choose
to
throw exceptions we haven't seen an
exception that's a way of being able to
say there's an error
in the code you do things like that it
really enables you as a programmer
to be able to really go in deep to your
code and understand at a very deep level
how it works
now obviously this program is trivial
it's like the easiest program we could
have written to be honest
and java programs they get of course
increasingly more complex
although don't worry because it's always
manageable complexity because of the
simplicity of the syntax of the language
that's the
combination of keywords and symbols and
that kind of thing it's quite easy to
get the hang of when you have a play
around in practice a bit but the point
is though once you take your programming
to the next level
you start developing more complex java
programs that's when you really start to
see the power of a debugger
so yeah debuggers and ide is essential
tool to have
in any programmers toolkit so that
should have given you a nice overview
of the main moving parts we have in java
programs and also a sneak peek into what
it's like to actually use an id
to do some java programming as you can
see once you know what you're doing it's
actually not that complex after all